nasa's first test mission of a project
to send humans back to the moon has been
postponed the agency is planning to make
history when it goes back to the lunar
surface in 2025 by setting up a base
there and sending the first female and
first non-white astronaut today's launch
had been to make sure that the rocket
system worked as it should but fuel
leaks have prompted a delay let's go
straight to cape canaveral and talk
disguise david blevins who is there
david what happened
well it's not the day we were hoping for
kimberly let me tell you how close they
came the vice president kamala harris
had arrived at the kennedy space center
here at cape canaveral on the florida
coast hoping to witness a moment of
history but she like the rest of us is
going to have to wait a little longer we
knew from early morning they were
dealing with a hydrogen fuel leak the
second in two days then things got worse
when they reported a conditioning
problem in engine three of the powerful
space launch system so ultimately they
had to stop the clock at launch pad 39b
and they will miss this window and we'll
try again probably on friday but despite
all of the ambition around this project
ultimately safety has to come first it
is a historic
program the artemis program they're not
just planning to return humans to the
moon but to put the first woman and
person of color there also to build a
permanent base from which they might one
day put humans on mars so it is a really
ambitious program people thought this
would be the day they would see it
launched but they're going to have to
wait a little bit longer